[Musica]
non sono mai stato un grande
appassionato di autoveicoli ricordo il
mio primo anno di studi in ingegneria
meccanica tutti i miei colleghi non
parlavano d'altro che di in quattro
ruote
io pensavo d'aver sbagliato tutto eppure
a due anni di distanza mi trovo
piuttosto spesso in quei luoghi dove
qualsiasi appassionato avrebbe sempre
sognato di essere ci sono capitato
avvale di un percorso di ricerca e di un
progetto di start up nata circa due anni
fa due anni nei quali abbiamo imparato
che la possibilità di fare impresa e
ovunque soprattutto o in particolare
laddove vi sia la possibilità di
investigare quello che il comportamento
di quegli oggetti e neri tondi e
rotolanti che sono gli pneumatici delle
nostre auto che tutti usiamo ma di cui
poi pochi effettivamente sappiamo
qualcosa mi occupo di dinamica del
veicolo presso la federico ii una
disciplina che studia l'interazione
delle nostre vetture con l'ambiente
esterno ed in questo ambito
lo pneumatico è qualcosa di essenziale
qualsiasi veicolo per quanto complesso
tecnologico deve fare i conti col fatto
che la principale fonte di interfaccia
con l'ambiente esterno è costituita da
piccole aree più o meno grandi quanto il
palmo di una mano
all'interno di queste aree viene ha
giocato una partita essenziale una
partita che può far vincere o perdere
una gara quando si parla di corse o una
partita che può salvare una vita
quando si parla di sicurezza stradale
queste considerazioni ci aiutano a
capire quanto sia essenziale ottimizzare
quello che avviene in queste piccole
aree
dopo circa dieci anni di attività in
quest'ambito con due amici soci abbiamo
sfondato abbiamo fondato uno spin off
accademico una società nata con
l'intenzione di evocare il luogo dove
oggi c'è il castel dell'ovo a napoli e
dove secondo la leggenda
il corpo della sirena partenope andrò ad
arenarsi e da lì ebbe origine il primo
insediamento della città di napoli gli
spin off accademici sono delle start up
delle società che nascono all'interno di
contesti di ricerca con l'obiettivo di
valorizzare i prodotti della ricerca
e operare quello che viene definito
spesso trasferimento tecnologico
ho sempre definito il nostro progetto
come un progetto dovuto dovuto perché
dopo anni di ricerche le nostre idee
erano lì e spingevano per abbandonare
quella loro dimensione del teorica ed
avventurarsi verso questo mondo della
competizione sportiva e questo questa
mobilità che sta cambiando in questi
anni in una rivoluzione che sta
diventando qualcosa che porta ai veicoli
ad essere sempre più interconnessi ed
autonomi il punto è che noi non sapevamo
come si diventa imprenditori come si
diventa start upper ricordo i nostri
primi passi la paura le prime notti
insonni il nostro logo schizzato sui
tovaglioli del bar i primi business plan
la grande euforia quando qualcosa si
arriva di fronte a noi e voleva
ascoltare quello che avevamo da dire
voleva far proprie le nostre idee ed un
po di sconforto quando quel contesto
accademico non tutti sembravano capire
realmente come una start up potesse
vivere all'interno del contesto
universitario
il primo anno lo affrontano con
l'intenzione di sviluppare una
tecnologia fortemente innovativa una
tecnologia che consentisse a chi guida
determinati veicoli di sentire il
funzionamento della gomma anche quando
siamo su delle auto virtuali durante il
dopo questo primo anno e mezzo
alcuni tra i primi player le prime
grandi aziende con cui dialoga vamo
nominarono questa tecnologia come la
tecnologia più innovativa a livello
internazionale nel mondo
dell'interazione tra pneumatici strada
ci trovammo d'improvviso catapultati in
un contesto totalmente nuovo eravamo in
volo verso hannover in germania dove
dovevamo ricevere questo premio era
estremamente emozionante e il secondo
classificato in un'azienda di 27.000
dipendenti né a quei tempi eravamo in
cinque eravamo in volo e ci domandavamo
quale potesse essere un moto di
schematizzare il percorso che ci aveva
portato fino a quel punto tra bravi
ingegneri prendemmo un foglio di carta e
disegniamo uno schema uno schema che
aveva due direttrici fondamentali
una prima legata al livello di maturità
tecnologica delle nostre idee la ricerca
tipicamente alimenti ai processi di
innovazione dal basso porta delle idee
ad uno stadio prettamente embrionale che
andranno ad evolversi nel tempo
progressivamente l'altra direttrice era
la platea di potenziali utenti
potevano fruire di quelle idee
inizialmente come tutte le idee che
nascono nelle startup le nostre si
collocavano in un ambito piuttosto
immaturo tecnologicamente e destinata
una platea di utenti piuttosto basse
qualsiasi start up qualsiasi azienda
ambisce al fatto che le proprie idee
crescano tecnologicamente e si rivolgano
a platee sempre più ampie se quindi in
quel momento andavamo ad analizzare come
le nostre idee si erano evolute vediamo
che quelle idee che sono queste piccole
crocetti né si erano disposte
effettivamente seguendo questo andiamo a
questo andamento
stavamo facendo quello che forse andava
fatto ma la cosa più interessante è che
in questo processo di innovazione
costante erano nate delle nuove idee
queste nuove idee alimentavano questo
diagramma dal basso in una maniera
totalmente nuova inizialmente le nostre
idee
abbiamo visto nascevano in una zona di
bassa tecnologia e di bassa platea di
utenti le nostre idee hanno cambiato
completamente approccio all'innovazione
nascevano in un contesto già proiettato
verso la grande rivoluzione della
mobilità e il feedback della ricerca
aveva cambiato il nostro modo di essere
ricercatori e di fare ricerca stessa
la grande fruizione il grande rapporto
che c'è tra ricerca innovazione aveva
messo in atto un processo di tangibile
innovazione che aveva cambiato noi
stessi quello che abbia che era avvenuto
riassumendo in qualche modo era che il
processo di trasferimento tecnologico
che tante volte nominiamo ovvero
prendere delle idee trasferirla in un
altro luogo era diventato un qualcosa
che era un interscambio tecnologico noi
davamo dalla ricerca e ri acquisivano
nella ricerca stessa qualcosa di
profondamente innovativo senza una
startup tutto ciò non sarebbe mai stato
possibile
un'innovazione specifica dal mondo delle
corse da dove eravamo partiti al mondo
dell'innovazione nella mobilità era
scaturita dal fatto che un algoritmo che
ci consentiva di stimare la valutazione
dell'aderenza tra ipnotici e la strada
per far vincere delle gare era stato
riportato al contesto della mobilità in
un contesto che quello della mobilità
autonoma che sta intorno a noi cambiando
in questi p in questi due anni sono
successe tante cose abbiamo un organico
in crescita il contesto della
l'innovazione territoriale è
profondamente cambiato abbiamo dei nuovi
poli universitari
abbiamo degli incubatori di impresa
abbiamo grandi player che investono sul
territorio ed avere una startup in
questo momento qui ci fa dire che sembra
di essere al posto giusto al momento
giusto
quel piccolo logo che disegnavamo sui
fazzoletti di carta
adesso lo vediamo in contesti ben più
ampi ricordo la prima volta che
assistendo al fatto che il nostro logo
venisse messo su una vettura ad alte
prestazioni ci eravamo sintonizzati in
streaming ad un evento per vedere questa
gara e nel mentre che nei box scrivevano
i preparativi c'erano le prime
interviste i tecnici si affannavano
vicino alle vetture notammo un operatore
che puliva meticolosamente il pilastro
dove di lì a poco sarebbe stato
attaccato il nostro adesivo perdemmo
qualsiasi attenzione per il resto
dell'evento quell'uomo aveva catturato
completamente la nostra attenzione
quella mano era diventata la mano del
nostro idolo per quei minuti
ora quel luogo e in ben altri contesti
siamo arrivati in motogp
siamo arrivati in formula è la rivista
italiana delle mighty aggiudicato il
progetto come uno dei progetti più
innovativi guidato da innovatori under
35 nel 2018 in italia e qualche giorno
fa il 15 ottobre eravamo alla borsa
italiana a ricevere un premio come una
tra le tre start up italiane di maggiore
successo di quest'anno
di tanto in tanto mi capita di
esperienza di talk con plate di neo
start upper o di studenti delle facoltà
scientifiche economiche e tante volte mi
viene chiesto quali sono gli
insegnamenti che ne abbiamo avuto da
questo percorso e che potremmo portare
agli altri
abbiamo imparato che la possibilità di
fare impresa e ovunque e ovunque
laddove vi sia possibilità e voglia di
investire in competenze la ricerca
rappresenta questo e tante volte ci può
partire da una competenza che può
sembrare veramente di nicchia che può
arrivare veramente ovunque la
possibilità di fare impresa e ovunque
laddove vi sia voglia di comunicare con
le persone
viaggiare può significare esplorare
nuovi contesti anche rimanendo ben
radicati al proprio territorio
ascoltare le persone capire quali sono i
loro problemi e cercare di risolverli
tante volte anche con la volontà di non
avere alcun tipo di tornaconto immediato
e ovunque laddove vi sia possibilità di
creare contaminazione probabilmente
l'innovazione è proprio lì prendere a
conoscenza da settori che inizialmente
sembravano non dialogare tra loro e
creare delle connessioni dei ponti che
portano laddove non si poteva immaginare
di arrivare ma soprattutto forse
la possibilità di fare impresa e dove ci
sono delle persone puntare sulle persone
perché sono le persone che fanno
succedere le cose creare valore dare a
un team la possibilità di credere che da
un contesto anche semplicemente legato
allo studio di quella piccola area di
interazione o da un contesto
territoriale lontano da quei centri
nevralgici dell'automobilismo
internazionale si possa fare la
differenza
il nostro progetto è nato per
consentirci di restare e di tornare a
napoli
oggi il nostro obiettivo è quello di
rendere delle nostre attività così
competitive da far dire a chi è altrove
io vado a napoli grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]